the City of Grand Forks North Dakota was
really happy when the potential for a
new cornmeal came to town well that was
until the citizens there learned about
who the company was associated with
they've told us repeatedly that Air
Force officials at the base have raised
no concerns they've told us that they
have properly vetted the fufang
corporation and they see no problem with
it which just it simply isn't true they
did a Google search that was their
vetting process of the company
well back in July the angle first
brought you the story out of Grand Forks
North Dakota of a Chinese company as you
just heard named fufang it's attempting
to build a corn Mill just miles from an
American Air Force Base well just
yesterday the committee on foreign
investment in the United States
concluded its reviews saying well they
don't have jurisdiction to block this
let me put this very bluntly
the committee that Congress mandated and
gave the authority to protect America's
national security is allowing a Chinese
business with ties to Beijing that means
the CCP to operate mere miles from an
American military installation
where's General Austin
how about Millie why are we spending so
much money on National Defense when
obviously no one in Washington intends
to defend this country here on our own
land at all
here now is Gordon Chang Gatestone
Institute senior fellow who's been
tracking China's land purchases here in
the United States for years
Gordon why we would allow China to buy
up
key agricultural tracks in the United
States let alone land near an Air Force
Base
I think people are just scratching their
heads tonight
well they've got to got to remember that
this company is Chinese and that means
in the Communist party's top-down system
it cannot refuse a demand to spy also
the Chinese 2017 National Intelligence
law article 7 and 14 require every
Chinese company to spy if they receive a
demand to do so so this is a company
under a compulsion to commit Espionage
this this let piece of land is within 12
miles of Grand Forks Air Force Base
they've got sensitive satellite uplinks
there this by its very nature is a
danger to American Security and whether
you Google it or not the Air Force
should have known that now the mayor of
Grand Forks had a interesting reaction
Gordon to the news yesterday watch this
initially I was surprised because they
had 45 more days we expected they were
going to take that full amount of time
so um they had a 45-day extension they
could have granted and asked for more
information from the two parties that
were involved
Gordon they didn't take the extension
that they could have used to thoroughly
look at this uh it seemed like it's
rushed through
is someone just trying to placate please
bend over backwards for the CCP in the
United States at this point is that what
we can conclude
you know that's the only explanation
that I can come up with you know and by
the way even if the committee on foreign
investment in the U.S felt it didn't
have jurisdiction the president of the
United States using his powers under the
international emergency economic Powers
Act of 1977 could prevent this land
purchase so there's a lot that can be
done we still need to keep the pressure
up but you know you're absolutely right
we have a white house we have a pentagon
that seems determined not to defend the
United States
well Gordon how many American companies
are being allowed to buy tracts of land
in China near Chinese oh anywhere let
alone near Chinese military
installations do you have a list of
those
zero zero Laura you know this is just
again it's an issue of reciprocity and
this is not the only case that we have
we have the Chinese uh former Chinese
officer actually bought a lot of acreage
near Laughlin Air Force Base in southern
Texas and there's another case of this
as well so this is seemed to be
symptomatic which means that the
Communist party is using these purchases
to spy on the U.S I mean how dumb can we
be
and Gordon yesterday almost 200 Chinese
companies avoided being delisted from
the U.S stock exchange after our
accounting Watchdog board claimed that
that have full access in you know audit
inspections later on here's the chair of
that board defending this decision
investors are better protected today
because the pcaob was able to send in
our inspectors and investigators and
really look at the books of the audit
firms in China and find out where there
are problems and now we're able to hold
those firms accountable to fix those
problems
Gordon is there any indication that due
diligence is even possible when you're
talking about the CCP their tactics and
their strategies against the United
States
no and what's even worse is that we send
our Auditors to Hong Kong where we
reviewed those books we didn't send them
into the mainland we didn't send them to
the companies themselves so I don't see
how we can say that we got due diligence
or we can hold them to account this just
was this was fundamentally wrong in
terms of the agreement in the first
place and the execution is worse Gordon
thank you so much hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else